The next scenario I'd like to discuss is,
the "Small But Mighty" BI Team.
This is when you're a part of a small group that knows how to use
Power BI well and creates tools that others can use.
But they're targeted to eliminate subject area with the focus
limited to specific areas like sales or finance.
In this sort of situation,
your stakeholders fall into
that specific area that your company chooses to focus their analysis on.
Your key allies are the business process owners or BPOs,
who know their data and needs.
Your key challenges might be translating the business needs.
In other words, getting those business process owners to clearly
define and describe those needs in a way that you can translate into our port.
This is where phrases like explain it to me logically step-by-step come in handy.
You may also run into data quality issues.
Sometimes, unfortunately, you'll be in a position where you'll have to gently
explain to folks that data doesn't exist in a way that will support their needs,
or that it's impossible to do some calculation or analysis
given data quality issues that need to be resolved at the source first.
You may have heard the phrase;
garbage in, garbage out.
The same rule really applies here,
but maybe use a gentler phrase if we're
talking to someone who helps to generate that data.
Your key opportunity might be to de-silo the data,
showing how seemingly unrelated data from other areas of
the organization can enhance analysis and decision-making.
De-siloing data can be a powerful way to
gather new insights that can empower decision-making.
As long as you can find the data and the joins to connect them,
you have all the tools you need to make that happen.